I'm here with Kevin Mayo.
He is a graduate of the Frontend
nano degree program, and
he is now a Frontend
engineer here at Udacity.
So Kevin, I wanted you to
talk to our students about
what you do when you
are learning a new technology.
Where do you go?
What sort of resources
do you find helpful?
>> Yeah, sure.
So I guess that's one of the skills that
I picked up from the nano degree is,
when you're trying to learn something
new, I usually go right to the official
documentation or official site,
whatever the technology has set up.
Pretty good nowadays about giving you
a little tutorial, code example, and
like, good documentation,
because basically, there's so
many new things coming out that if
you don't provide good documentation,
nobody's going to use your technology.
So, that's like,
the best place to start, and
just get some kind of a feel for it.
And then obviously you're going to
have questions, or I always do.
So then that's when you can
go to the Udacity forums.
You can go to Stack Overflow,
just Google things.
But usually I like to jump as
quickly as possible into a project,
so it can be a simple to do app.
Everybody does those.
Or like a Udacity project.
That's a great starting point too.
And just kind of go,
trying to actually build something,
that's where you'll
start to have questions.
And you're kind of forced to learn.